ma questo presentissimi questo
nuovissimo vivissimo di sic si
secondissimo ragazzi allora l'ultima
partita che ho fatto avevo trovato un
miliardo e mezzo di bottiglie d'acqua
che impossibile attrae c'era posto
sarebbe più rara dell'oro e zuppa hard
per baciare 0 c'è una roba impossibile
volevo vedere se riesco a giocare in
modalità bomba zar la bomba zar sarebbe
la modalità finale di xiv secolo c'è la
difficoltà potare io già non lo finisco
in easy profitto noi ragazzi sono
quartieri storici esiste consono a
quattro anni e quattro sì sì se vince da
4 anni 4 anni l'ho vinto una volta una
sola ed eroina o in norma venisse
comunque non ero mai in bombazza roveri
bombardarono mai fatta e vedrete perché
allora ghazi partiamo subito con il
fatto che siamo in due
e secondo me questo è un vantaggio è un
vantaggio no in realtà perché tu ogni
volta a cosa servono i membri della
famiglia servono per sacrificarli a
portare le provviste che se non servono
quindi niente razioniamo provviste rosso
ragazzi si definisce il tempo in cui
posso dargli da mangiare cioè che vi
devo dare da mangiare di spesso non
credo credo sia solo una questione di le
cose che trovi sono molto più risicate
gli imprevisti che succedono sono tutti
negativi poche parole non crolli bisogna
dare cibo più velocemente o apcom e
ancora dovrebbe essere uguale però ai
ragazzi anzitutto non abbiamo la
maschera quindi andiamo andiamo subito
team 1 spedizione perché sono poi non ho
provviste c'è qualcuno all'uscio ma
forse rivolta richiamano il soldato
americano apriamo non so ragazzi se
effettivamente di copiare aprire io
facessi però è solo per provare la casa
tema di inizio stato no io ci ha rubato
tutto ci ha rubato anche la famiglia
abbiamo certo lo fa ci ha dato europa e
io che pensavo che aprire la porta e
modalità difficile fosse morte certa
invece no non siamo soli sembra che ci
sia un coniglio enorme però a volte tira
fuori la testa e pisano ma cosa lo
sguardo famelico le nostre mise le
scorte di cibo lo possiamo permettere
che le prenda vai usa lascia ted che sei
grande e grosso povero coniglio è un
coniglio radioattivo
non dovrà mai successa volare coniglio
tra l'altro non era mai successa prima
volta però ogni minimo dorata che non si
basi all'istante in questo rifugio è
impossibile che qualcosa no rimasto un
no libertà paletto è quello sfugga la
nostra ricci che secondo sì il mattone
vai a controllare l'apertura vai trova
una zuppa ti prego perché anzi è l'acqua
quali servirebbe effettivamente
nell'acqua timi è morto il minore più
tornar lo fa tornando libro però finché
non me lo dice il gioco non è morto tech
non è più assetato sembra molto debole
se non mangiava cosa potrebbe firmare
finire male vai mangia questo riferito
poi abbiamo pronti mi per favore torna
cos'ha portato cos'ha portato niente
mappa straccia bravo team i complimenti
reggano sta andando male ora che poi la
modalità più difficile non è male
fidatevi che non è male sai che vi do
acqua e cibo a tutti e due e poi li
vediamo quando darvi acqua e cibo perché
non lo so
anzi tende cibo non o se avete abbiamo
né l'altra sono in due a per orgoglio
posso buttare fuori vescovo tende fuori
quindi non idonea te vai amico mio la
mappa la mappa è stracciata non la posso
usare quindi lascia bye bye combatti
non so cosa vi serva la chabrol e in
base agli oggetti di un sì secondo me
loro sopravvivono di più o portano più
europa cioè secondo me ai ragazzi
portare oggetti fuori serve dipende
dall'oggetto che porti però non ho mai
il nome approfondito la cosa ti minors
ancorati milan a più sette team yamaha
mai mangiato ieri timi ma basta ted sarà
fuori una settimana è quindi fino a
giorno 20 non lo vediamo state
tranquilli ve lo dico io
acqua e cibo per timi dire che se li
merita visto che quasi morto con la
zuppa ma è del tutto questo eccolo lì
almeno non muore lui muore anche ted
quindi abbiamo perso raga abbiamo perso
però c'è il tentativo quanto zuppa
contribuente ai trend suprema è pazzo
come fatta tra l'altro le zuppe anche la
radio bravissimo gravissimo è lo stomaco
i tempi brontola e quindi roda tenta
contratto moriranno tutti ragazzi
mariano tutte non facciamo qualcosa per
la malattia di team rischia di
peggiorare sì certo cosa devo fare
timmy potrebbe farcela potrebbe anche
non farcela ragazzi
domandare tv per forza che se non mi
muovo parte che mi vuole lo stesso primo
amore uguale o almeno tenta di morire in
modo onesto cioè va fuori a cercare
provviste e poi ci sono gli amici che mi
proteggono quindi forse team di ancora
malaticcio massa che fosse potrebbe
potrebbe farcela e il tanto lo mando
fuori vediamo se lo riscopre sesto
potere qualcosa non gli toni niente
perché va bene
timmy baie porta roba possibilmente un
kit medico per te stesso perché sennò
non schiatti ma magari anche un altro
per tuo padre potrebbe avere senso con
un ragazzino chiama medikit merenda si
chiama hamed kit sono io che non so
l'inglese e la fame è guarito sembra
vero pinera possa vedere qualcosa dovrà
bere sicuro ma mangiare no ci ha fatto
visita un commerciante il cavallo
imbarazzo dice avremmo la borsa e tutto
ciò che contiene tanto il piatto lo so
io che il gatto lo so perché eccola lo
sento giornate però ragazzi modalità
difficile e non vorrei dire chuikov esci
e portare del cibo subito so perché ma
mi piace avere sciatico pintorno veniva
bene non ci sta una bottiglia
non mi ricordo quando è uscito timi ma
secondo è morto perché una vita che non
c'è più seri colucci quindi è anche
utile perché ammazza gli insetti gap
dimmi dimmi che ha mandato mezzi per te
stesso no però portato la maschera ha
portato avere un fucile st portato così
a casa come tv riuscito a tornare o bene
che bello ricevere aiuto dallo stato
il nostro amico mutante ha mantenuto la
parola portato un suo paio di compari ci
siamo dichiarati divertiti quanta
spedizione siamo tanti e rifugio sunny
estate o beni che serve è servito
veramente reagan che offrono solo in
modalità difficile sono bravo io faccio
pagare nella moneta facile ma in
difficile riesco a fare cose incredibili
non so come è peccato da non ti può
assicurare temi quindi ti lascerò morire
però bob berg york non gli do da
mangiare
un'ottima proprio spedizione quando ted
ragazzi perché è messo bene non è anzi
lo posso anche mandare tra l'altro con
la maschera quindi niente male livelli
delle elezioni p mib bene mangiare
assolutamente i veli della iniezioni
come sono non me lo dicono va beh mando
lo stesso lui tanto oro per ogni volto
perché tanto il fucile non ai colpi
quindi cosa lo porto a fare il fucile
per intimorire la gente non lo so cosa
serve fucile ragazzo nike o il pd oggi
lodo in testa io porterei la maschera ma
solo ed esclusivamente perché se nota ma
lì e non so se il giorno 33 le
radiazioni si sono abbassate sai perché
questa la modalità difficile quindi
magari le radiazioni non si abbassano
mai capito quindi l'ok per non saper né
leggere né scrivere lo mando la maschera
ragazzi sto io ho perso partite molto
prima e siamo in modalità di film non
sono messi a possibile tutto questo è
meglio abbiamo scoperto che carico 489
giocattolo un pezzo di cablaggi innocuo
chissà cosa serve togliere il cavallo
storico croda ispezionarlo si può magari
è qualcosa che serve che è tornato the
di tutto quel giorno 40 cibo bomba zar
ecco ted e mara come può essere malato
con la maschera attimi non ha più secca
e dei magnati mi faccia bagnato ma era
pertanto sono biliardo riproposte ted
vai con la maschera non lo so perché
pieno di banditi fuori regali che è
successo che succede
vi ha schifato i giorni ma cosa come ho
fatto a perdere alcune cose è meglio che
rischio inviolate sconosciuti si sente
la foglia troppo tempo ed è morto
va bene ti mi era molto malato
l'apoteosi carlo è morto timi così 60
giorni quasi è in modalità difficile
modalità bomba zar 60 giorni partitone
part guarda frizioni successo 4 su 5
perfetto per importi per una difficoltà
che era veramente perfetto decise risi 9
decisioni no2 niente male
18 oggetti quattro volte difesa no
ragazzi partita un incredibile poi che
io l'ho mica faceva impossibile vincere
però partitore non lo possiamo negare
sono sicuro ai ragazzi questo rapitori
cece seconds di today sono molto
soddisfatto dei miei progressi giusto
gioco perché mamma mia come vi sia
piaciuto cosi tragicamente e mi piace
anche se le si schieri come sempre ci
vediamo alla prossima vita della ragazza
[Musica]